This is our day on our year!
If the government gets away with this, then
what the fuck happens to us next?
What happens to everybody next?
This is about freedom, it's about freedom
from persecution, freedom from profiling,
you know, freedom to be who you want to be.
The district will be hosting a number of protests
on and around the National Mall this weekend.
We started off this morning, loaded the van
up, headed up here.
The Juggalos are marching on Washington DC.
The FBI has decided that we're a gang.
We're exercising our first amendment that
we have the right to gather
and we have the right to listen to whatever
kind of music we want
without being labelled a gang.
It's our mark on history.
It's our mark on history, it's showing the
world who we are.
We've been hiding under the streets for way
too long and we're about to come up top
and show everybody who we are.
We're at a DC cafe right now and we're watching
Juggalos interact with DC folks,
people that are here all the time.
It's workin' out.
I'm all the way from Utah up here doing this
so.
That's so fun, well awesome we're happy to
have you so you know.
We got people from Colorado, California, you
know, Illinois, everywhere.
Do you really think, this guy in fuckin' face
paint, in clown paint, is intimidating?
Do you really think my black ass is that intimidating?
I grew up like this, and a goth kid in middle
school, surrounded by rednecks,
so that's my upbringing.
But it helped me stick out, it helped me define
myself.
They're staying at my house, he's at my house,
she's at my house, she's at my house,
I've got fifteen people there right now.
I've driven countless people to and from the
airport, to their hotels.
We're not gang-banging freaks, we're just
people you know.
But we're a family.
Then from two o-clock to ten 0-clock at night,
that's the Juggalos march.
That'll kick off down at the Lincoln memorial.
Over here at the Lincoln memorial, you're
gonna see tourists and school groups,
and families taking pictures.
And over here, you're gonna see where the
Juggalos have started to assemble.
And everybody over here isn't quite sure what
to make of what's happening over here.
So the thing about following, say, Clown Posse,
is that you go to lots of weird shit towns.
So it's very weird to be, not only in a city,
but in one of the most important cities in the world.
In a place that is sacred to American democracy.
That's why you're here right now, you're in
the crowd to be proud,
you're the ones that demanding no discrimination.
We stood here and watched for hours and listened
to the speakers
along with the fans of the band and we didn't
see any trouble at all.
This is our day on our year!
Are you ready?
The march has started, they're gonna go down
the reflecting pool,
they're gonna go around the monument, and
then come back.
There's a lot of media here.
There is no such thing as an ordinary Insane
Clown Posse show.
It's always a spectacle, it's always an event,
there's always something wrapped up in it.
This is about freedom, it's about freedom
from persecution, freedom from profiling,
you know, freedom to be who you want to be.
And to not be unduly hassled, that's crap.
If the government gets away with this,
commit such a blatant act of discrimination against us Juggalos,
then what the fuck happens to us next?
What happens to everybody next?
You never know.
Today was a day where Insane Clown Posse evolved,
it kinda went from being one thing to being
another thing.
I think they- I think the challenge was to
show the world that Juggalos are good people,
that Juggalos are a law abiding people, that
Juggalos love each other,
and are a positive force for the community.
And I think that's been illustrated here.
Love always wins every time, and we're marching
for love,
Juggalo family love!
The thing about the Juggalo world is it's
so, kind of ramshackle,
and yet there's this miraculous sense that
it all kind of comes together in the end.
And I'm looking at the Washington Monument,
you know, and the National Mall,
and the feeling that I have right now, you
know that's, again it's,
yeah, it's like a high.
It's like a definite high.